I'm not dead yet I don't know um you
just keep trying I mean we try to look
at all the elements available to us as
environmentalists artists architects
builders craftsmen and distill each of
those down and create a kind of palette
in which each of those disciplines
becomes part of your brush stroke and
you create a painting by not ignoring
any one of those things or taking one
for granted and synthesizing them so I
guess are we try to use the landscape
use the building and use the interior
seamlessly and maybe we're exploring
that also we've straddled a kind of ism
of their kind of two camps that have
always existed there's the kind of
abstract camp in the realist camp
throughout history and when modernism
got very popular and the kind of idea
that we could live in utopia as
modernism in the machine would replace
man it was a fantasy and an experiment
that really didn't work so then we saw
after that whole kind of modernist thing
and you see a low-cost housing which
ganged on to the idea of utopia which it
really wasn't in fact there's a place
called the utopia parkway which is kind
of hilarious but so all these towers and
all these core boozy and Marseille
blocks were built with the hope of being
utopia but without the master doing it
himself it's hard to assimilate utopia
and it was also a kind of fantasy so
after that movement we moved into a kind
of historicism in a post modernism in
which everybody was grabbing on to
something from the past because they
felt as though their future had failed
them so then we got past that and
modernism BK Dan isn't it became a
revivalism so now
we're kind of in that modernist
revivalism and then there's this whole
group of the orthogonal and the
rationalist and then there's the flying
shrapnel and the irrational and you have
those two things going on but but Peter
and I have tried to do is find a way to
link those things together through a
string in our worth not turn our back on
the past but not give up on the future
either and how we could work in context
in a non-literal way in a somewhat
abstract way to bring the past and the
present in a kind of synthesis and I
think that's navigating that line is
very interesting